[Musik]
bis bald gast ist die blm juni dank für
die freundliche einführung und natürlich
für die einladung hierzu metaphysik als
begriffs logik oder so ähnlich sprechen
zu dürfen wenn man den das täten das
thema dieses kolloquium es dieser
kolloquiums reihe anschaut das hat mir
ganz gut gefallen weil hegels
analytische philosophie als theorie der
bedeutung klingt ja so als wollte ich
das nur sprachphilosophie machen und
deswegen benutze ich das grad als die
chance zu sagen nein bitte so ist es
nicht gemeint es ist schon metaphysik
die frage ist nur was metaphysik ist und
dieses verhältnis von sprachphilosophie
und metaphysik ist jetzt heute auch ein
thema ich werde ihnen kein handout geben
weil also ich denke das sind keine
thesen die man nach hause tragen kann
sondern eher selbstverständlichkeiten
die man sich erinnern soll und aus
diesem grund reicht die akrobatik also
das zuhören
dazu noch eine kleine vorbemerkung ich
meine das thema metaphysik und
anthologie hat ja als hauptfrage die
frage was es gibt
jemand der auf eine etwas versierter
weise diese frage beantwortet und nicht
erst wie aus der pistole geschossen
auflistet was es so alles gibt der wird
natürlich und nicht nur wenn er
heidecker heißt zurück fragen was das
dann überhaupt kreis zu zu fragen also
was überhaupt dass es gibt oder das ist
bedeutet und ich denke dass das in der
tat der zentrale bindeglied ist zwischen
logik oder sprachphilosophie auf der
einen seite und ontologie wenn ich die
frage was das ist das natürlich auch
lateinischen oder im griechischen es
gibt heißt was das bedeutet und ich
werde ihnen jetzt nicht eine regel
vorlesung mache hier vortragen über wie
die seines logik dann beginnt in der
überlegung was das ist so alles bedeutet
nur ein punkt jetzt gleich am anfang die
schwierigkeit von hegels logik und das
seinen beginn hängt damit zusammen dass
er sagt oder dass er vorschlägt die
frage was es gibt nicht als ganz an den
anfang zu stellen sondern an den anfang
zu stellen
die frage worin oder in welchem bereich
unterscheiden wir etwas also der
vorschlag von hegel scheint mir der zu
sein
erstmal muss man unterscheiden und erst
danach können wir fragen ob es das sind
das gibt und dazu braucht man natürlich
in bereichen in denen wir etwas
unterscheiden und deswegen die sie ganz
allgemeinen bemerkungen zu beginn das
ist schon eine kleine revision dessen
was ich 1992 in hegels analytische
philosophie gesagt habe jetzt aber
möchte ich ihnen vielleicht ein bisschen
polemisch etwas sagen warum wir eine
erneuerung der philosophie durch
reflektion auf die logik brauchen und
dann etwas zum begrifflichen seinen
empirischen werden und zum begriff des
begriffs und zur arbeit am begriff also
am schluss kam es dann doch wieder zu
hegel zurück der beginn
ich beginne mit einer geschichte und
zwar mit einer geschichte
hans georg gadamer war mehrere male in
leipzig und ich habe nicht immer um ihn
kümmern dürfen oder müssen wie sie
wollen
insbesondere bei einem
bei einer tagung der damals noch
allgemeinen gesellschaft für philosophie
wir sind damals auf einer längeren reise
nach weimar zusammen im auto gesessen
und haben uns über philosophie
unterhalten und einsatz hängt im ohr hat
mir damals gesagt wir verstehen immer
noch nicht was ein begriff ist und in
einem bestimmten sinne ist es ein
merkwürdiger satz
denn spätestens wenn man ein bisschen
gebildet ist in der analytischen
philosophie meint man doch zu wissen
dass uns gott wird träge und die
sprachphilosophie da weitergebracht hat
also dass wir jetzt wissen was ein
begriff ist
indem wir in der begriff schrift als
läge eine allgemeine logik des begriffs
entwickeln sie wissen ein begriff
beiträge ist eine funktion und ein
anständiger begriff oder ein prädikat
als funktion oder als funktion mit zwei
werten ist dann auf eine bestimmte weise
man könnte es verkürzt sagen eine
klassifikation von gegenständen in einem
schon ausgegeben unterstellten sozialen
bereich also wir haben gegenstände und
die werden abgebildet auf wahr oder
falsch und das ist ein begriff
das problem ist also solche gegenstände
können zahlen seien menge dingen
ereignisse mögliche welten was sie
wollen bei möglichen welten sind dann
sind setzten dann zwar positionen aber
eigentlich in positionen die man die
einführt in der logik oder in der
sprachphilosoph schießen ja eigentlich
eigenschaften sind ja eigenschaften von
menge das problem in diesem zugang ist
dass man die gegenstände noch mal dinge
ereignisse mögliche welten einfach
voraussetzt führt überhaupt nicht gesagt
was dinge sind es wird überhaupt nicht
gesagt was gegenstände sind oder mit
die welten und man unterstellt sie als
diverse entitäten und deswegen jetzt
haben wir eine andere anthologie wir
haben den glauben oder die unterstellung
von ontologien als and its bereich über
die man redet und meine polemik die ich
gerade eben angekündigt habe gegen diese
tradition der analytischen philosophie
sagt das eigentlich interessante der
logischen analyse nämlich was diese
gegenstände sind wird dann einfach
weggelassen
das heißt es wird einfach unterstellt
ist sei klar was eine mögliche welt ist
und was eine funktion von möglichen
welten in zwei werte ist und dann wird
herr umgerechnet statt dass man fragt
das eigentlich der begriff der
möglichkeit nicht zu klären ist in dem
man ihn voraussetzt oder der begriff des
dinges indem man ihn einfach
voraussetzen dass da eine punkt ich
denke dass einer ein weiterer punkt der
mich in eine merkwürdige lage dringend
nämlich ich meine bildung stammt aus der
analytischen philosophie und meine
interessen haben sich in richtung hegel
verschoben weil ich unzufrieden war mit
bestimmten antworten die man da liefert
und das ist schon merkwürdig dass man
aus dem zwanzigsten jahrhundert um
bestimmte unzufriedenheiten wir sind ins
frühe 19
zurück taucht haben wir das nicht schon
überwunden und da denke ich dass wir in
der pflegerischen tradition also in der
tradition der formal analytischen
philosophie auch meinen wir hätten
relationen verstanden also nicht nur
prädikat und in einem sinne stimmt es
weil die frische antwort was in der
relation ist ist ganz ähnlich wie die
die regel auch kennt das kennen sie auch
auf simfy.de als plattform
wo er sieht dass so ein scheinbares
prädikat dass dinge nur klassifiziert
wie delikat ist groß also sie mias ist
groß oder kies ist groß dass das
eigentlich eine relation ist also das
gäbe es ist groß relativ zu sokrates und
seminars ist groß relativ zügiges und
dann sieht man dass der plattform
benutzt das um zu sagen nein nein
wahrheit ist nicht relativ wie pro tag
was meint sondern der hat nur nicht
verstanden wie das mit den relationen
ist relationen brauchen den mathematiker
sagten parameter an vergleichs
gegenstand und genau so versteht träge
relation
das problem ist dass mathematische
relation und ist größer kann man so
verstehen aber die relationen die uns im
welt bezug interessieren
das sind meistens prozessuale relation
kann man so nicht verstehen reicht nicht
aus und ich denke dass dessen zweites
ein zweiter punkt ist also die normale
analytische tradition sagt uns zu wenig
was gegenstände sind wie konzentriert
sind und sie sagt uns zu wenig was
relationen und prozesse sind und auch
wenn sie formale analysen zu diesen
dingen liefert das reicht nicht aus
stattdessen brauchen wir eine logik die
überdies regel logik der komplexen
definition von formalen relationen und
formalen prädikaten hinausgeht wir
glauben ja
dass die frische logik eine logik des
argumentieren sie man argumentiert indem
man über die festlegungen der semantik
von logischen kollektiven wie nicht und
und und für alle komplexe definitionen
macht wie es ist eine primzahl und dann
entsprechend richtig schließen kann so
dass wir diese logik verwenden können
zum scharfen definieren von begriffen
und zur kontrolle des richtigen
schließen
was wir dabei übersehen ist dass das
eigentlich wenn man mal ein bisschen mit
einem zahmen blick drauf schaut nicht
eine logik der wahrheit sondern eine
logik der definition ganz bestimmter
prädikat ist das also eine technik der
verdichtung der als der ausdrücke und
daraus kann man dann wieder das merken
was man hinein gelegt hat ist also in
einem bestimmten sinne keine
argumentative logik sondern
definitorischen logik des und free
geliefert und auf eine bestimmte weise
ist es ein riesiges missverständnis dass
die logik eine theorie des schließens
wäre also weiteres problem das sind wenn
eigentlich die interessante schlüsse
jedenfalls nicht die so würde ich jetzt
behaupten das ist die dritte polemik
gegen diese tradition der analytischen
philosophie nicht die die uns etwas
durch die formale logik ableiten lässt
damit sehen wir dass die frage der rolle
des formalen logischen schließens und
der konstitution von sakralen
gegenstands bereichen in pflege sinne
wenn man genau hinschaut leider den
bereich des mathematischen der
mathematischen logik da nicht verlässt
und die projektion der mathematischen
logik auf die sprache die echte
philosophie dass sprache nicht die
philosophie der mathematischen sprache
diese
wird massiv unterschätzt sogar so noch
dass leute die die brände oder wie
vorher auch schon oder kreis meinen ihre
analysen der sprech handlungen
formalisieren zu müssen und damit meinen
noch einen positiven schritt zu tun
statt dass sie sehen würden dass das
gerade ein schritt in die falsche
richtung also so ein bisschen polemik
wie sina das betrifft jetzt die wenn sie
so wollen ontologischen schwierigkeiten
der analytischen philosophie
jetzt fangen wir noch mal neu an und
gucken an die klassischen probleme der
metaphysik nämlich die frage der
ontologie was sind denn die
voraussetzungen dafür dass wir überhaupt
variablen gegenstände der iss gibt im
logischen sinne verwenden kann
und da geht es ich habe es eigentlich
schon mal gesagt jetzt wiederhole ich
noch einmal es geht um die überwindung
der naiven voraussetzung von entitäten
oder anthologien und wie geht das
wie können wir die überwinden das
zauberwort das nur den titel benennt ist
konstitution
ich denke dass wir daran erinnern müssen
dass dieses zauberwort das gar kein
zauberwort ist sondern das zentrale wort
erkannte schon überlegungen aus der
kritik herein sondern sozusagen das
geheimnis des weges weg von der
juristischen tradition ob die logische
und gerüstet ist mit regen oder nicht in
eine neue ebene der kritischen
metaphysik oder der kritischen ontologie
führt es geht bei kant natürlich und
unter dem titel die bedingungen der
möglichkeit der erfahrung ist die
bedingung der gegenstände der erfahrung
und die müssen wir verstehen wir müssen
verstehen was gegenstände der
erfahrungen sind
ohne gegenstands konstitution bleiben
die heißt dass meine kleine vorgriff
kleine these ich denke dieser gedanke
der gegenstands konstitution unter der
analyse das sind denn eigentlich dinge
zum beispiel der wird bei hegel schlicht
nur für allgemein hat aber das ist eine
unglaublich bedeutsame verallgemeinerung
weil jetzt wird die frage gestellt was
ist denn überhaupt die bedingungen der
möglichkeit der rede von gegenständen
überhaupt seien sie formal wie in der
quantität phan-thi täten logik ist
nichts anderes als die logik der mengen
zahlen größen also der reinen
mathematischen gegenstände als auch der
empirischen gegenstände oder der
gegenstände oder dinge die wir als
ursachen von erscheinungen und damit als
diesen ansprechen und täglich frage ist
die verallgemeinerung der kantischen
frage der konstitution der gegenstände
und solange eine analytische philosophie
die frage nicht in das zentrum setzt
also die frage wovon redet wenn ich von
möglichen welten rede wovon rede ich
wenn ich von zahlen rede wovon redet
wenn ich von fiktiven gegenständen rede
wovon redet wenn ich von gott und
staatlichkeit rede bevor ich irgendwas
behaupten muss ich das erst mal
beantworten bevor ich bevor die
analytische philosophie diese frage
nicht aufgreift ist sie nicht analytisch
oder kritisch genug ist sie vor kritisch
dass meine kollegen und beispiele für
die naiven haltungen zu anthologien
kennen wir in der mathematik unter dem
titel platonisch muss der ja auch in der
philosophie der mathematik bis heute
herrscht weil mathematiker sind ja gar
nicht interessiert an der konstitution
der mengen die glauben an die kantone
menge leere
aber was das bedeutet dass man über ab
zählbare mengen annimmt hat noch nie
jemand sachs etwas polemisch
ernsthaft überlegt argumentiert wird er
hat das ist nützlich hilbert noch aus
diesem paradies will er sich nicht
vertreiben lassen
nat nur wenn wir über pragmatische
argumente argumentieren dann gehen die
eigentlich zum beispiel metaphysischen
fragen sowieso über den jordan wenn ich
nur sagen das nützt etwas könnte man zum
beispiel die ganze ontologisch
metaphysische debatte zwischen
naturalisten oder physiker listen die
sagen ich glaube das einzige was es gibt
sind dinge die sich nach bestimmten
gesetzen bewegen und der andere ist
vielleicht christlich gläubiger der an
die unsterblichkeit der seele und den
engel glaubt und dann gott den schöpfer
und dann könnte man wenn man nur
pragmatisch argumentiert man sagen also
was nützliches als die religiösen
glauben gibt es sowieso nicht
also aus dem in der auseinandersetzung
unter pragmatischen gesichtspunkten
macht es überhaupt keinen sinn busse
durch london fahren zu lassen dass es
unwahrscheinlich sei dass es einen gott
gibt weil unter pragmatischen
gesichtspunkten hätten die argumente
schon verloren wie ein plagiat ist
william james ja längst schon weiß also
so kann man nicht argumentieren hat das
wir haben also ein problem die dass uns
die pragmatischen antworten auf die
anthologien nicht weiterhelfen und die
komplex die ganzen geschichten sind und
das sozusagen alles in der theoretischen
philosophie von dieser frage abhängt
sieht man bis hin in die philosophie des
geistes ich sammle jetzt sozusagen
anwendungen um ihnen zu zeigen dass das
tatsächlich brennende probleme sind
in der philosophie des geistes wird dann
viel hinten zu david sohn iranischen ein
beispiel als beispiel einer solchen
theorie des an normalen muñiz muss und
da wird gesagt ja wir haben etoken
identität es der geistigen mentalen akte
und der physikalischen abläufe im gehirn
nett man kann sich damit zufrieden
stellen das problem ist solange er nicht
geklärt haben was dieses schöne wort
zogen eigentlich heißen soll also wovon
wir eigentlich reden wenn wir von der
eigens drucken von einzelnen ereignissen
sprechen die identisch sein soll als
mentales ereignis und als physikalisches
ereignis wenn wir so lange wir glauben
ereignis typs eine menge von solchen
typen und mir nur so reden machen wir
gar nicht dass wir von gar nichts reden
wir haben eigentlich nur ein
mathematisches bild im kopf und das
heißt in einem bestimmten sinne hat man
man meint man würde sprach
philosophische argumentieren in der
edition iranischen tradition
aber man weiss nicht einmal dass die
tradition der philosophiegeschichte uns
längst schon darüber belehrt dass so ein
einzelnes das jetzt ganz schnell weg ist
als individuum szabics dh das ist das
gar nicht gibt es gibt es natürlich aber
nicht als gegenstand über den wir
sinnvoll regeln könnten oder auch nur
zum wohl denken können das heißt mit
anderen worten alle lösungen dieser
tradition in diesen bereichen hängen von
der frage wovon reden wir überhaupt ab
und auf eine bestimmte weise ist eine
kritische philosophie die die frage
stellt wie sind denn die gegenstände
konstituiert notwendig um
der physische glaubens haltungen die
noch nicht einmal wissen woran sie
glauben als solche zu kritisieren dass
da eine clubtour mathematik oder crypto
mathematische vorstellungen dahinter
stecken macht das ganze nur schlimmer
weil wir nämlich auch schon aus der
philosophie tradition wissen dass crypto
mathematische modelle der philosophie
nicht weiterhelfen
aristoteles hat ja bekanntlich schon
über neo kategorische tendenzen der
plattform schule polemisiert und sagte
denen ist die philosophie zur mathematik
geworden sagte an einer bestimmten
stelle
dh sie merken in meiner ankündigung dass
ich mich sozusagen mit einer formalen
logik nicht wohl fühle
in dem bereich der ontologie haben sie
jetzt vielleicht verstanden warum das so
ist
im grunde kann man da ein merksatz
daraus machen alles was ich jetzt gerade
eben gesagt habe hängt wesentlich damit
zusammen dass man glaubt über solche
gegenstände sprechen zu können sowie die
mathematiker sprechen nämlich als
individuelle gegenstände die wir
vereinzeln können und der terminus
technicus ist so thaler gegenstands
bereich also da hat man gegenstände die
sind gleich also haben eine identität
für sich wie die zahlen und sind
voneinander verschieden und in den
zahlen haben wir dann ganz scharfe
begriffe weil die ja weit auseinander
sind die zahlen zwei und drei haben
da gibt es nichts dazwischen und sogar
zwischen brüchen und reellen zahlen
diesen schönen diskret es auch wenn das
alle anderen betrachtung kontinuierlich
jetzt nur vorteile gegenstands bereiche
die bereiche die wir voraussetzen müssen
um überhaupt die ganze definitions lehre
der tragischen logik in gang zu bringen
gibt's nicht außerhalb der mathematik
alle dinge in dieser welt entstehen und
vergehen haben kontinuierliche grenzen
und haben eine ganz andere sichtweise
als die mathematischen ding und ich
denke das steckt im grunde im kern und
am anfang und vielleicht auch bis zum
schluss als eine der tiefen einsichten
in hegels logik dass er immer wieder
darauf aufmerksam macht dass wenn ihr
und das ist übrigens ganz interessant
also sagt denn der so ried ist also der
das scheinbare paradox des kahlköpfigen
dass wir alle wagen begriffe sozusagen
nie scharf kriegen das ist sagt er das
ist kein das ist kein paradox so da kein
sufismus sondern ist eine tiefe wahrheit
für all diese bereiche und daraus folgt
dass wir nicht wissen was
umweltbezogener begriff ist wenn wir mit
ihm so umgehen wie in das register
analytischen philosophie und das ist der
grund warum ich denke dass da mal recht
hat dass wir noch nicht wissen was ein
begriff ist
wenn wir weil wir noch nicht wissen dass
es gar keine fatalen gegenstands
bereiche in der realen welt gibt sowie
die vorausgesetzt werden müssen wenn wir
überhaupt formale logik an wände so dass
wir ein problem haben und dieses problem
betrifft jetzt das begriffliche sein und
das empirische daten ich habe die
kontinuitäten gerade eben benannt
und ich denke dass darauf zumindest
müssten nach meiner sicht regel versucht
einige antworten zu geben
mich interessieren im moment nicht die
feinheiten der unterscheidungen zwischen
formal analytischen
und also analytischen setzte derart
junggesellen sind unverheiratet und
tierischen setzte nur der eine punkt ist
empirische setzte heißen deswegen ab
hysterie oder weil ihre
geltungsbedürfnis tor ist wir müssen
abwarten bis etwas geschehen ist und
dann können wir nachher sehen ob es
barbist eigentlich ganz gut gewählter
ausdruck apriori sind sätze die hand
vorschlägt nicht deswegen weil wir ohne
in die erfahrung der welt einsteigen
müssten die bürger die im kopf
verbreitet haben sondern apriori sind
sätze weil sie an ganz bestimmten status
und eine solcher status ist so dass die
geltung nicht so ist dass ich abwarten
muss was geschieht wie bei den abo
stereo die setzen
und trotzdem gibt es synthetische also
nicht rein formal analytische also nicht
rein verbal definitorischen setzte die
ab juni sind dass man tegel zu recht
eine große entdeckung dann kann man
jetzt geht es nur darum dass wir
möglicherweise bei kant zu wenige mich
zu viele synthetisch urteile
synthetische urteile apriori haben der
unterschied zwischen einem wissen a
priori und abo stereo die ist also
keineswegs wie man in der tradition des
britischen empirismus meint einen
unterschied zwischen einem angeblich
angeborenen oder mystisch nicht
empirischen vorher wissen und einem
empirischen wissen sondern ein status
unterschied der sätze die periodischen
artikulieren das ist jetzt ein vorschlag
zeit allgemeine insolvenz leben
die apostolischen sind historisch war
und eben damit hochgradig in sexy
kalisch also wir brauchen in neue
definition des empirischen des
apostolischen und wir brauchen das
in bezug auf diese unterscheidung dass
das ist das sozusagen generisch
allgemeine ist ist im man anzeichen dass
soll ab jetzt ab juli gelten und apriori
heißt das ist einfach eine in friends
ticket mit dem ich weiter zumindest es
ihm gefällt oder normalfall rechnen kann
während die empirischen sätze haben
immer die gleiche form also dass da
hinten ist grün oder was ich gestern
gesehen habe war das und das es ist also
denkt tisch in bezug auf den sprecher
und deswegen ab osterode und wir
brauchen also eine neue definition des
empirischen auch im kanton ismus weil
bei kann selber das leider nicht scharf
genug ist und wenn man das mal sieht
dann sieht man dass wir auch die gesamte
grundlage ein bisschen jedenfalls in
bewegung setzen müssen vielleicht
erinnern sie sich noch was ich
angekündigt habe was die frage des
arbeits der arbeit am begriff ist eine
meiner themen arbeit am begriff bedeutet
wir entwickeln die prioritäten die
material begriffliche na prioritäten
begrifflichen vorher wissen es auf eine
allgemeine war und das tun werden
keineswegs in der philosophie sondern in
den wissenschaften also die wissenschaft
ist nicht eine anhäufung empirischen
wissens das wäre anhäufung empirischen
wissens das wäre informationen das nicht
wissen in der wissenschaft geht es um
die kodifizierung begrifflicher material
begrifflicher normal erwartungen die in
begriff qualifiziert werden also neue
auch da ein neuer blick den vorschlag
natürlich eines neuen blick auf das
verhältnis von philosophieren
wissenschaften ist deswegen so wichtig
weil dann die philosophische logik
möglicherweise nicht das herumspielen
mit formalen definitionen analyse
hart sind analytisch jetzt im sinne von
was wir mit nicht und für alle
definieren können sondern was ganz
anderes möglicherweise hat viel gerecht
dass die logik wie er das nennt
spekulativ sein muss das heißt in meiner
übersetzung meter stufige topographien
logischer landschaften liefert und das
was ganz anderes als die logik in der
frischen tradition
das führt uns weiter zu der frage wie
sieht es mit dem apulischen vorher
wissen aus warum ist das für eine
kritische philosophie insbesondere für
eine metaphysik kritische philosophie
tatsächlich der zentrale begriff ich
will jetzt gar nicht über einzelne reden
periodisches vorher wissen grenzt das
was als wirklich anzunehmen die
möglichkeit zählt nämlich aus gegenüber
bloß verbal analytischen inkonsistenzen
und der ball analytischen inkonsistenzen
was also bloß aufgrund der regeln für
nicht und für alle oder analytischen
definitionen für unmöglich gilt lässt
für den bereich des möglichen einen viel
zu großen bereich interessanterweise ist
deswegen eine jüdische oder eine
formaljuristische tradition da keine
kritische philosophie weil sie viel zu
viel für möglichkeit das heißt je mehr
wir die partie als aperiodische es
vorher wissen haben desto weniger desto
enger wird bei bereich der sinnvollen
möglichkeiten und so dass wir am ende
sehen dass sogar kranz sinn kritik
gerade weil es viel zu wenig
aperiodische bedingungen drin hat ich
rede jetzt gar nicht welche das sind es
natürlich die geometrie das sind die ram
zeitlichen bedingungen aber die ist zwar
viel strenger als viel strenger als der
logischen empirismus aber noch
viel zu weit so dass für regel sind
solche möglichkeiten die also nur in
diesem sinne seien denkbar sind immer
noch wie er ironisch sagt unmöglichkeit
und daran kann man sehen wenn wir
kritische philosophie betreiben müssen
wir einen robusten und realistischen
möglichkeit wie chris entwickeln
demgegenüber die formalen spiele der
möglichen welten ob das bei partnern ist
so ist oder bei david luiz entweder nur
formale mögliche welten sind oder
vorstellungen von möglichkeiten mit
denen wir gar nicht wissen dass man
damit anfangen sollen
ich werde daraus noch zurückkommen
also kritische philosophie und das ist
vielleicht auch ein geheimnis dass wir
von kant lernen können kritische
philosophie hat wenn es um diese
metaphysischen fragen was es gibt geht
die hauptschwierigkeit zu klären was ein
vernünftiger glaube an möglichkeiten ist
und damit was überhaupt
vernünftigerweise als möglich zu
behandeln ist und das ist in der tat die
schwierige aufgabe und die schwierige
frage der philosophie
ich will sie jetzt hier nicht
beantworten ich will nur sagen wenn wir
wenn wir die diese frage nicht angehen
wir fliegen sozusagen in dem er die
möglichen welten einfach voraussetzen
haben wir die kritische philosophie
schon verlassen
und was genau diesem grunde hat kann
völlig zu recht in der kritik der reinen
vernunft gesehen dass der zentrale punkt
in den grundsätzen die ist zu klären was
es überhaupt sinnvoll möglich ist zu
glauben jetzt natürlich bei ihm in bezug
auf die erfahrung was vielleicht auf
eine bestimmte weise
problematisch ist in seiner abgrenzung
aber immerhin hat er das stichwort
gegeben also mit anderen worten
kritische philosophie
mit den möglichkeiten zu tun und diese
möglichkeiten werden eingegrenzt durch
das atrio rische verheerendsten jetzt
erwarten wir dabei häufig viel zu viel
nämlich wir erwarten dass der abt rio
rische vorher wissen ein universales
wissen also keine ausnahmen lässt dass
es sozusagen notwendig sein soll
das wort notwendig ist ein schwieriges
wort weil es ja scheinbar komplementär
ist also das notwendige entspricht dem
unmöglichen ich muss ja nur eine
verneinung reinschreiben das meiste
wissen ist nicht notwendig das meiste
wissen ist generisch wie man aus der
linguistik seit schon 40 jahren weiß und
sagt und generisch heißt dass es für das
g nuss im allgemeinen gilt aber dass es
ausnahmen gibt
ich habe vor kurzem doch bestimmten
zufall in grimms wörterbuch den eintrag
zu unfall gelesen und unfall ist ein
saal der kein fall der also nicht zu den
normalen fällen gehört und das bedeutet
dass die unfälle und im englischen ex
ident eben als kontingente ausnahmen
nicht zum vorher wissen des generischen
falles gehört und wenn man das versteht
dann sieht man dass das vorher wissen
dass aperiodische vorher wissen von dem
ich spreche als generisches darf man
nicht übertreiben
auf der anderen seite mit unfällen
jedenfalls mit voll kontinenten umfeld
macht es keinen großen sinn zu rechnen
wir müssen also unterscheiden zwischen
das absolut unmöglich ist und mit
welchen möglichkeiten wir sinnvoll
rechnen müssen
das zeigt schon wie kompliziert diese
frage nach den möglichkeiten ist
abgesehen davon dass eine grammatik eine
ganz schwierige grammatik hier dahinter
steckt nämlich die der kante übrigens
auf eine schöne weise klar macht es ist
etwas ganz anderes zu sagen das ist
möglich oder das ist unmöglich und zu
sagen ich halte es für möglich ich
rechne damit und die frage ist was ist
primär die oppositionelle haltung oder
dass es ist möglich und kann suggeriert
wenn man liest dass das primäre die
haltung ist und der sekundäre dass es
ist möglich und das ist in der tat eine
tiefe einsicht bekannt ist es leider ein
bisschen schwankend
aber ich denke dass bei hegel wird klar
die haltungen sind das primäre und dann
sagen wir wir können das und sollten das
für möglich halten und dann lassen wir
den sprecher weg und sagen es ist
möglich das heißt die anthologie des
möglichen ist konstituiert aus der
nominale sierung wenn man so will und
bewertung der vernünftigen möglichkeiten
im sinne von haltung und dieses denke
ich ist ein schachzug den ich als ich
damals die hegels analytische
philosophie aus der logik her entwickelt
habe noch nicht gesehen habe ich denke
die phänomenologie des geistes ist
deswegen so wichtig weil sie diesen
schachzug den schachzug des primären der
haltungen gegenüber den objektiven
behauptungen
hervorhebt die objektiven behauptungen
sind ja nicht sprecher frei und das ist
ein weiterer polemik gegen die satz
analyse der analytischen philosophie die
tut so als hätten die sätze bedeutungen
unabhängig von entsprechen und den
haltungen und meint man könnte von ist
möglich sprechen
und als wären die nicht bloß
versicherungen derart wir können das wie
möglich halten
es sollte also klar sein dass die
haltung des glaubens an möglichkeiten
auf dem prüfstand steht
und solche haltungen werden jetzt zu
beurteilen seien in bezug auf macht es
sinn sich so zu verhalten damit zu
rechnen und so weiter nicht könnte man
das in bezug auf die metaphysischen
themen und sterblichkeit und
unsterbliche seele und gut machen aber
man kann es genauso gut an den anderen
haltungen den gegen haltungen eines
naturalismus festmachen die haltung des
glaubens an einen pre determinismus sind
der naturwissenschaftlichen vorstellung
alles sei kausal bestimmt ist nämlich
auch nur als haltung zu beurteilen weil
die behauptung selber aus dem boden zu
stampfen sagen aber es ist so muss ich
ja auch immer wieder sagen und warum das
was sie die gründe die dich dazu führen
diese haltung zu haben und ich denke
dass man dann wieder ganz neu anfangen
muss zu sagen ist es richtig oder falsch
zu glauben an oder an einen solchen rede
termin es muss sozialismus oder
physikalisch muss zu glauben oder nicht
weil manche meinen das wäre nicht eine
glaubenssache sondern es wäre eine
behauptung oder tatsachen sachen das
wird uns natürlich dann zur weiteren
ontologischen frage was eine tatsache
ist wir werden darauf noch zurückkommen
das ist nämlich führt sofort zur frage
was eine empirische tatsache ist und was
solche prinzipiellen tatsachen sind
empirische tatsache rostock ist eine
historische angelegenheit aber
sozialismus oder kommunismus das kleine
historische angelegenheit da können wir
nicht warten sondern entweder glauben
was jetzt oder haben die haltung dazu
oder nicht also ich sind gar keine
empirischen sätze sind gar keine setzte
der konzertierenden auf und als diesem
grunde kommt jetzt die nächste runde die
fragen was denn verschiedene tatsachen
begriffe wie die zu fassen sind in einem
bestimmten sinne hilft uns da die
tradition die ja die empirischen
aussagen immer als historiker der
theorie ja gegenüber gestellt haben
lange zeit hieß die theorie ja auch
philosophieren in der theorie und
philosophie an geht es um generisch
aussagen also um allgemeine orientierung
und nicht um historische tatsachen
deswegen ist da die rede von empirischer
wissenschaft leider irre führen die
wissenschaftlich noch einmal nicht
empirisch sondern sie kanalisiert eine
theorie und das ist hat massive folgen
für eine neue blicke auf die analytische
philosophie des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
und insbesondere den gründer jetzt nicht
pflege und wastl sondern der tractatus
der wittgensteins tractatus der im
grunde das gründungsdokument des
logischen empirismus ist und der hat
ebenen tatsachen begriff der wenn man
genau hinschaut nur den bereich der
historia abdeckt und genau das ist jetzt
kann man das sozusagen sich merken
die empirische und historische wahrheit
ist nun mal nicht
die wahrheit der naturwissenschaft
obwohl er das im tractatus sagt es sei
sozusagen richtig nur das zu sagen was
die wahrheit in der naturwissenschaften
sind sein sollen aber das was er dort
als wahrheit begriff liefert kein
einziger satz der naturwissenschaft ist
von der form so dass wir im tractatus
sozusagen der kultband den sündenfall
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts sehen
können und die frage des späten
wittgenstein ist wie komme ich von
meinen sünden los und die ironie dieser
frage vielleicht werden sie kennen also
zurück zum begriff des begriffs ich
denke und vielleicht ist es für sie
jetzt etwas zu viel des guten und
trotzdem möchte ich immer von der
systematik mit auch in die geschichte
zurückgehen weil ich denke wenn man die
geschichte mit zwei augen hat kriegt man
an etwas bessere geographie für die
verhältnisse und einer der mir
jedenfalls da immer die leitlinien
vorgibt ist plattform
ich denke dass platz an in sogenannten
ideen lehre von der alles mögliche in
der welt herrscht an meinungen etwas
ähnliches entdeckt hat natürlich nicht
auf eigenen überlegen allein gegründet
das kern bord der ideen lehre im
griechischen mythos wie wir wissen nicht
woher das kommt ganz selten vor nur im
siebten buch der polizei
etwas zu übertreiben ansonsten steht da
immer ein wenn sie die übersetzung von
eidos anschauen da steht natürlich wenn
man den kontext berücksichtigt ist es
vorn im englischen meistens form im
deutschen idee was ein fremdwort ist es
kann auch struktur heißen kann genossen
generische gestalt gattung art begriff
begriff ist die richtige besetzung
jedenfalls die tägliche und daher können
sollten wir platons ideen lehre als
begriffs logik rekonstruieren genauer
platte und logik der dialektik
attachment thematisiert die tatsache
dass alle ewigen beständigen nicht bloß
historischen wissenschaftlichen
wahrheiten im sinne des panini das
allgemeine aussagen über sich
wiederholende formen betrifft und unsere
debatte um ihre wahrheit als teil dessen
aufzufassen ist was hegel jetzt bin ich
wieder soweit arbeit am begriff nennt
das heißt plattform entdeckt wenn man so
will dass es in der wissenschaft und in
haiders anfordern um strukturen geht und
in der wissenschaft um die debatte
welche strukturen und sozusagen die
närrischen insolvenz erwartungen und
möglichkeiten vorzuschlagen sind fit zu
kanalisieren sind alles ist möglich und
es ist wahrscheinlich und es hier zu
sein pegel geht es war übrigens in
seiner reihenfolge von historischen
darstellung was er dem heraklit und was
er denn familien das vorschreibt er
falsch herum also er meint noch der
heraklit werden später als promi needles
und trotzdem hat er unabhängig von dem
zeichen historischen ordnung hat er wie
ich denke sehr genau verstanden dass die
systeme das stehende wissen also das
generische ist ist die generischen
wahrheiten und die doxa das ist okay das
was mir so scheint oder was erscheint
oder was empirisch bloß war es und es
geht in der wissenschaft um das stehen
um die app ist häme und nicht um die
dogs und zwar schon bei heraklit und
ganz besonders bei kaminers und platten
das ist jetzt wichtig weil für hegel
pegel kaub genau diese unterscheidung
jetzt mit neuen technologie auf nämlich
die unterscheidung zwischen realität und
wirklichkeit
die wirklichkeit ist das stehende wissen
sind die gegenstände bestehenden wissens
oder genau genommen sind die gegenstände
insoweit sie über das stehende wissen
verstanden sind und die erscheinungen
sind die ist die tractatus geben also
das was wir sozusagen beschreiben können
in bezug auf bloß erscheinung
also in bezug auf plus empirische
historische apostolische setzte und
genau deswegen wird in hegels logik die
ausdifferenzierung des ist so zentral
also das 1 1 ist ja nur die benennung
des ist und deswegen wird so zentral die
unterscheidung zwischen an sich seien
für sich sein und anderen für sich sein
als als die drei aus differenzierungen
das ist das an sich seien ist das
generische also etwas ist an sich etwas
wenn es für das ganze dennoch somit so
ist
wir würden zum beispiel sagen an sich
fressen löwen an sich fressen lösen
gazelle im zoo nicht aber sonst schon
und dieses an sich ist natürlich ein
ganz anderes an sicherheit das an sich
sagen oder das ansicht ist kant dessen
hinter welten oder grenzwertiges ansicht
ist aber ein ganz anderes ihr das an
sich bei hegel ist es ansicht des
deutschen und das deutsche verwendet das
wort an sich oder im prinzip oder im
allgemeinen ebenso dass wir sagen
der satz des generisch ganz in ordnung
das für sich sein ist der zentrale und
schwierige begriffe hielt ich behaupte
jetzt einfach und lasst mich nicht
darauf ein
in diesem vortrag nachher können wir
ewig darüber reden
ich denke dass das für sich sahen bei
igel den gesamten bereich der
gegenstands konstitution den gesamten
bereich der bestimmung von einzelnen
aber soweit es gerät da ist nicht so
weit ist sozusagen mystisch als token
nur unterstellt wird thematisiert und
deswegen kann er sagen dass für sich
sein ist das schwierige weil da steckt
ein sich drin und eine relation also
eine identität der relation zwischen
verschiedenen und besser müssen wir erst
mal verstehen also das für ist nämlich
pro ist eine relation
es geht um das für sich sein realer
repräsentationen von gegenstands artig
gerät barren dingen und zwar um die form
des für sich sein weil in der anwendung
ist es an und für sich sein und bat geht
immer um die konkreten gegenstände gerät
konkret hegel denkt immer lateinisch und
griechisch konkret zum kommt vom
zusammenwachsen der generischen
allgemeinen wissen und der dem physik
sein dass die einzelnen bezugs und hier
brauchen wir das besondere der
projektion beider des generischen und
der identitäten der gegenstands
bestimmung und deswegen ist sozusagen
die wahrheit des an sich sein zimmer
natürlich das andere für sich sein
aber das ist jetzt nicht nur titel
wörter im grunde geht es hier nur darum
zu sagen solange wir nur über generische
dinge sprechen haben wir die projektion
auf die reale welt vergessen solange wir
nur über reale erscheinungen reden haben
wir vergessen dass wir die realen
erscheinungen immer schon gierig
verstehen also immer schon theoretisch
immer schon auf über das an sich seien
verstehen john macdougall sieht immerhin
dass das bei hegel zu finden ist also
unsere wahrnehmung der welt ist immer
schon theoretisch geformt das heißt wir
können immer nur was allgemein war das
besondere ist ein besonderes allgemeines
und damit wird auch klar dass die
berühmt-berüchtigten drei schritte bei
hegel in seinen gliederungen die sind ja
immer dreigliedrig da gibt es eine
wunderbare also ist übrigens gibt
natürlich zu jedem philosophen immer
wieder wie das tigers beschreibungen die
auch so viel taugen wie die reader's
digest und diese bei hegel sagt man die
drei schritte die den walzer des hügels
definieren das ist these antithese sind
ist unglücklicherweise spielten nur das
eine wollen nicht bloß velten gar drei
gliederung kommt nämlich aus dem an sich
seien für sich sein und an und für sich
sagen kann man nachweisen dass die
einzige gliederung die er hat und genau
deswegen hat die zweite liga und nicht
wegen these antithese sind ist die hat
nichts mit also wie gesagt wie das
deutsche ist was anderes
und jetzt kann man sehen dieses an sich
für sich und an und für sich ist selber
schon eine logische diesem bewährung des
ist weil wir in den normalen setzen die
mal so mal so mal so lesen können das
beispiel dass ich jetzt gerade eben
gebracht haben der löwe frist oder ist
ein tier das gazellen frist
das kann ein ganz normales empirisches
ist seien nicht verweise auf den löwen
im zoo aber es kann auch ein generisches
ist sein also im amt im modus des an
sich seins und das ist eine ganz andere
dieser berührung oder analyse als die
die die erkannt machte er nämlich ihn an
ähnlichen beispiel kann man
bekannt dass auch aufweisen wo er nur
unterscheidet zwischen ob die nominal
phrase einen allgemeinen gegenstand
benennt oder an einzelnen benennt das
ist wichtig da es ist also wichtig ob
das einzelne allgemeines oder besonderes
ist bei kant in der nominale phrase aber
es ist noch viel wichtiger auf das ist
zu achten als auf die nominale straße
und das ist genau die leichte
verschiebung die aber vielleicht dann
doch eine große ist verkannt zu pflegen
übrigens um bei löwen zu bleiben
die tatsache dass eidos eine form ist
und sogar als begriffene inference
fahren das kann man wunderbar sehen
sonst würde das was wir alltäglich
benützen also es gibt ein schönes buch
die sich alle kennen wahrscheinlich
metapher sweater forstwirt bei von 26
metaphern könnten wir gar nicht
verstehen wenn wir nicht wüssten dass
inbegriffene in friends bedeutung hat
als in friends moment würde hegel sagen
und klassifikation moment das klasse die
katholische moment in dem in der
metapher richtig hat ist ein löwe ist
klar falsch berichtet ist kein löwe da
ist kein tier sammeln ist ein mensch
aber dass in friends moment das
stereotypische generische erwartungen da
sagt tapfer sein soll kann ich ohne
weiteres übertragen obwohl ich weiß die
klassik katholischen moment spielt keine
rolle
nur weil ein ei das sowohl im jahres-
oder ein haus als auch das eidos im in
friends in der in friends bedeutung oder
wenn sie so wollen in der disposition
allen bedeutung hat nur deswegen
funktioniert mit tassen und deswegen
denke ich kann man sehen dass wir
dringend und zwar wirklich unbedingt neu
überlegen müssen was umweltbezogener
begriff ist ich habe meine polemik war
die frische tradition kann den begriff
der klassische katholisch verstehen ich
werde jetzt keine einstellung ein echter
begriff umweltbezogener begriff ist
immer theoretisch und in finanziell
dicht und disposition l dicht dicht ist
natürlich angeführt in der ethik gewesen
aber es ist schlicht und einfach die
notwendige aufnahme einer überlegung die
die analytische philosophie selber
entwickelt hat mit der berühmten diese
oder eigentlich einsicht von der theorie
abhängigkeit der erfahrung in den 30er
40er jahren
wenn man die richtig deutet dann sieht
man eine polemik ist also gar nicht so
ernst gemeint
ich will nur sagen die eigene
analytische tradition wird klarer wenn
man sie in die allgemeinen kontext
gesetzt und nicht vergisst was wir
leider möglicherweise tun wenn wir uns
zu sicher fühlen in der analytischen
tradition so dass mein vorschlag jetzt
der wäre zu sagen ja wenn wir mit einer
neuen sichtweise sowohl auf die frage
des begriffs als auch auf die
philosophiegeschichte schauen dann
werden wir möglicherweise sehen dass
auch solche dinge wie das dispositionen
zentrales thema sind das die kräfte die
unsere renzi allen prozesse die als
normalfall erwartungen mit einem genuss
von dingen tieren was auch immer
verbunden sind ein teil des
begrifflichen sind und dass die
sogenannten kausalen erklärungen
begriffliche erklärungen sind dass das
jetzt nicht mehr so weit hergeholt ist
und dass die wirklichkeit von der kegel
spricht mit der
wir die erscheinungen erklären
tatsächlich geistig ist weil die
begriffe geistig sind also
institutionelle von uns gesetztes wissen
ist und nicht ein bild der kausalität
des entweder mechanisch ist ein ereignis
hat die anderen regelmäßig zur folge
oder hobbys iranische das im
wesentlichen die billardkugel kausalität
wäre sondern wir haben hier eine ganz
andere beziehung zwischen der
wirklichkeit und der erscheinung
dass das gar nicht so weit weg ist und
vielleicht auch nötig ist denn platz und
dann neu zu lesen das können sie bis hin
in die verbindung von eidos und psyche
sehen die kräfte die der plattform den
planeten in ihren bewegungen zu schreibt
sind die psyche
das sind die kräfte die dafür sorgen
dass die planeten sich in diesen
prozessen der form der reproduzierenden
form der planetenbewegungen erhalten die
psyche in diesem kontext ist nur die in
den gegenstand den gegenstand
zugeschriebene normaler fahrt erwartung
dessen was er für normale prozesse
liefert und das erklärt dann auch die
aristotelische tradition von
der analyse der psyche und ich denke
dass das hegel wie sie alle wissen der
ist ja begeistert von der anima dass er
das weiß und in dieser tradition
natürlich die psyche und das alles in
einem bestimmten sinne identifiziert
jetzt kann ich das im wesentlichen noch
einmal abschließen indem ich sage was
machen wir in den wissenschaften in den
wissenschaften wird alles historische
getilgt und wir lassen dort oder
kanonisierten situations in variante
allgemeinen aussagen gesetze oder
bedingte in friends regeln und die
werden sprachliche artikuliert und genau
das sind naturgesetze naturgesetze sind
nicht etwas die über eine welt ansicht
dass aussagen sondern sind
vorgeschlagene rahmenbedingungen für die
begrifflichen fassung der welt und die
arbeit am begriff ist die arbeit der
wissenschaft deswegen meint hegel wenn
er von wissenschaft redet in der tat
wissenschaft die logik als
wissenschaftler logik ist dann wie ich
das ausdrücken eine logische geografie
der reflexion stern mit denen wir über
realität und wirklichkeit an sich seien
und für sich seine konstitution der
dinge und ihre erscheinungen die
verschiedenheit der erscheinungen und
die gleichheit der dinge reflektieren so
dass das thema der logik als spekulative
logik alles alle diese reflexion termine
sind und nicht die direkte und das ist
genau der punkt war damals sagt
naturphilosophie will die logische
geografie der natur machen der die
wollen keine bessere naturwissenschaft
machen oder wie ja jedenfalls nicht wenn
wir das richtig verstehe und jetzt
können wir auch sie in den welchem sinne
man die logik als fortschreibung der
ersten mit philosophie oder der
metaphysik des aristoteles lesen kann
es geht hier darum dass die begriffs
logik die klärung des begriffs ist mit
der stufe natürlich und das ziel ist die
neue sis neues ios das wissen was wir in
der wissenschaft machen und wenn
aristoteles sagt dass das göttlich sei
dann ist es natürlich im bilde gemeint
dass nur ein logisch geklärtes wissen
ein selbstbewusstes wissen ist und ich
denke in genau diesem sinne kann man
dann hegel sowohl in der phänomenologie
als auch in der logik verstehen dieser
berühmte satz was uns praktisch bekannt
es ist noch lange nicht erkannt spricht
schon bände in diese richtung und das
vielleicht ein klein bisschen einblick
geben warum ich denke dass hebel aktuell
ist jedenfalls wenn meine sicht auf
diese dinge
ich danke ihnen für die aufmerksamkeit